well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight kind of an amazing story
to bring you newly released surveillance
from the parkland Florida shooting has
just been released
it shows former deputies Scott Peterson
the person in charge of protecting the
building
arriving outside at the moment that
Nicholas Cruz was conducting his rampage
Peterson then stood around for several
minutes as the shooting occurred and did
nothing
17 died also documents just obtained by
Judicial Watch show how egregious this
failure was Peterson's failure training
manuals from the Broward County
Sheriff's Office explicitly instruct the
first officers on the scene to confront
the shooter of course that didn't happen
just the opposite tom Fitton is the
president of Judicial Watch and he joins
us tonight Tom great to see you anything
so there was some confusion when we
first learned that this deputy in charge
of protecting the students there was
some speculation that perhaps we've been
told not to or that the department
required him to wait for backup not true
no the manual says he may go in and the
training materials that we obtained
under the Florida sunshine law the
classes and the materials show you're
instructed to try to stop the shooter as
soon as you're able whether you're one
deputy two deputies showing up three or
four and and and the language is pretty
striking they say every time you hear a
shot
you can presume another person is being
killed and so the instructions are to
try to confront the shooter as quickly
as possible because the analysis was
after Columbine as soon as the shooter
is confronted by an individual who's
armed whether it be a police officer a
school security officer or civilian
who's carrying a concealed weapon the
shooter engages right shoots back and
forth or commits suicide
either way the shooting of innocents
beat stops and it's upsetting to read
these documents knowing what actually
happened that day and it shows a failure
by Broward County Sheriff's Department
either the properly trained as officers
or in the case that maybe the current
off of the officer who had to resign in
disgrace
obviously he ignored the training if
indeed he followed it so
this wasn't some hidden thing this
wasn't a stairs in the training manual
and it's I think that's relevant because
sheriff Israel in the days after the
shooting went to the CNN gun-control
rally and sat on the stage and blamed
armed citizens blamed the middle of the
country basically for what happened and
never mentioned the failures of his
deputy but he must have known that this
was the protocol wouldn't he have known
that that's right and you know other
deputies arrived and they didn't go into
the building as quickly as they should
have either and they talked about if you
have four deputies go in you're supposed
to form up in a quad they call it a
diamond formation and go in and confront
the shooter it's you know what are their
words it's because I think there were
four deputies outside armed during the
shooting and I did not immediately enter
the building Peterson was there three
others showed up and it took them a bit
to enter the building and Peterson
should have been there immediately he
could have gone in by himself another
deputy arrives they could have gone and
gone and together they they recommend if
you go in together there's a technique
for approaching a shooter if you're just
a two-man team what's frustrating about
this you see this material and you
recognize what the failure was in
parkland that led to the needless deaths
yes and we suffered through these these
ridiculous demonstrations yesterday know
what ridiculously I mean kids kids you
know fear for their safety they came out
and said what they thought but it has
nothing to do with the situation of
Parkland Lodge which was a failure of
law enforcement to follow their own
protocols and protect innocent civilians
and on top of that we now know about the
FBI failing to follow authorities failed
to protect us they lied about it and
blamed us that's right and now the talk
is with the politicians we're gonna take
away guns I'm hurt nothing to do with
protecting kids in school so rather than
accept blame they turn an outward on the
population edible documents and you know
frankly our viewers should go look at
them though we're going to be pretty
darn upset when they see what the
training was because they're gonna see
the training as being extremely
informative and my gosh that has been
fire wise we even followed lives would
have been saved tom Fitton Judicial
Watch thank you very much for that
you're welcome